je vous propose des jeux de société de
l'entreprise Cocktail Games basé à
[Musique]
Versailles on commence par le jeu happy
City le but bâtir la ville du bonheur
carte après carte vous devrez choisir
les bonnes tactiqu pour rendre vos
habitants les plus heureux poss
possiblees une partie dure 30 minutes
vous pouvez y jouer entre deux et 5
personnes fan des caraoke shabada est
fait pour vous formez deux équipes et
tireer une carte sur cette carte de mot
il vous faudra alors trouver ou chanter
un maximum d'extraits de chansons
possible avec ce mot pour gagner vous
pouvez y jouer entre 4 et 50 joueurs
faux rire garanti enfin top 10 un jeu
coopératif innovant et drôle les joueurs
devront répondre à l'un des 500entèmes
du jeu en fonction de leur carartes par
exemple quel objet fallait-il avoir lors
du naufrage du Titanic tous ces jeux
vous promettent de beaux moments de
complicité parfait comme cadeau pour les
fêtes de fin d'année